ça fait plaisir aux enfants comme nous
en mange pas souvent à chaque fois c'est
un événement et ils aiment bien comme la
télé les écrans tout ça c'est très rare
c'est que pour le lancement de société
en plus c'est horrible parce que moi je
me crois quand je dis des trucs comme ça
sur les bords du lac de Serre-Ponçon
plus grand réservoir d'eau douce de
robes de l'Ouest le chef de l'État est
venu esquisser les grandes lignes du
plan o tous les secteurs seront mis à
contribution avec une première ambition
c'est avant tout un plan de de sobriété
d'efficacité pour l'eau dans la durée un
simple parapluie non un bouclier capable
de repousser un agresseur
un projectile et même les objets les
plus solides on y résistent pas c'est
génial redoutable ce parapluie
syndicaliste habitants des Hautes-Alpes
ont réservé un accueil tout particulier
au chef de l'État pour son premier
déplacement en région depuis plus de
deux mois
[Musique]
le président vient aujourd'hui pour
parler de la gestion de l'eau eux
veulent évoquer la controversée réforme
des retraites bah écoutez maintenant il
sert aux personnalités jusque là c'était
des valises blindées qui se
transformaient en écran de protection en
louvré comme ça et ça permettait de
protéger les présidents de la République
en cas d’être depuis ce parapluie voilà
ça c'est la valise ce parapluie fabriqué
par l'entreprise de Cherbourg ça
servante pas protège tous les présidents
ou depuis Nicolas Sarkozy c'est génial
pourquoi vous êtes venus ce matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire quoi usage de la force là
ça permet de les faire de les repousser
tranquillement vers le tranquillement ou
en force tranquillement pour le moment
on est trop content laissez passer les
policiers c'est nous on arrive direction
stp
[Musique]
pour autant dire que la République doit
s'arrêter et qu'on doit dire on doit
attendre de revenir sur les sujets de
sécheresse dans un mois la réponse est
non on doit continuer de travailler avec
beaucoup de respect de calme au milieu
de cette bousculade on a repéré 7
pancarte Manu on t'aime mange déconne
mais le président n'était pas dans ce
cortège la question des 64 ans vous ne
reviendrez pas dessus mais je vais pas
redire la même chose tous les quatre
jours sinon bégaye on va faire la
retraite à 60 ans et comme dit
l'expression un peu populaire roule ma
poule et casse des œufs en l'occurrence
tout ira bien la fameuse expression que
seul Olivia Grégoire emploi qui va à la
chasse perd sa place ramène du gibier
sauf si on arrive à recoller les
morceaux l'année dernière on a une
sécheresse exceptionnelle par rapport à
ce qu'on connaissait mais elle ne sera
pas exceptionnelle par rapport à ce
qu'on va connaître
qui arrive à point nommé opportun
oui on a un litre sur 5 qui est perdu à
cause des fuites ce qui est inacceptable
sur la table 180 millions d'euros par an
et un soutien particulier aux outre-mer
territoire ou la situation est parfois
critique des travaux importants sont
nécessaires notamment pour rénover les
réseaux existants oui ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps mais il faut commencer
et il faut essayer d'accélérer le
processus
qu'il faut changer les
[Musique]
choses
pour demain bon et ben ceux qui
insultent sur les réseaux sociaux
puisque j'ai pas toujours envie de
porter plainte parfois ça m'arrive je
réponds le mec il me dit tu es con je
lui dis tu es trois fois con
même tu vois
c'est quoi pour vous les trois trucs que
le Japon a qu'on aura jamais en France
le respect je pense
Pierre Edouard Manu on va on se dit
quand même enfin on est en Corée du Nord
là c'est pas possible quoi quand même et
pourquoi
[Musique]
mais non mais pourquoi tu dis Corée du
Nord non alors là c'est toi qui manque
de mesure pour la première fois ça n'est
jamais arrivé que tu m'agaces mais là
vraiment ça m'agace que tu dis ça alors
je supporte pas on vous présente comme
l'anti Martinez c'est vrai ou pas intime
Martinez mais c'est avec qui me présente
comme ça moi je suis anti-capitaliste
anti Macron
anti-mader anti-exploitation moi j'ai
pas d'ennemi dans mon organisation on
n'est pas assez pour se disputer ne dis
pas qu'on est en Corée du Nord parce que
c'est pas vrai en Corée du Nord elle
serait déjà en tôle là elle ne va rien
payer et elle n'ira pas en tôle donc on
n'est pas encore
faire très attention aux analogies il y
a trop de gens en France aujourd'hui qui
disent qu'on est en dictature alors
qu'on est en démocratie et il y a trop
de gens qui me foulaient au pied la
démocratie la République aujourd'hui à
l'extrême gauche Luke Skywalker au
service de l'Ukraine
[Musique]
Marc Hamil prête sa voix l'application
qui alerte la population
ukrainienne d'un Bombard demandé russe
déjà nommé ambassadeur de l'armée des
drones par le président zellenski
l'acteur de 71 ans prodigue ses conseils
de Jedi aux Ukrainiens
et leur donne un peu de courage
[Musique]
il en faut vraiment peu vraiment très
chaud
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle s'appelle Colette maze elle a 108
ans et elle joue du piano tous les jours
[Musique]
commencent par où ma visite qui aurait
des flèches
bon il reste des pâtes de fruits au
moins
Colette ne bois pas beaucoup d'eau elle
boit beaucoup de vin combien de vin vous
buvez
plutôt une demi-bouteille par repas un
demi-verre c'est sûr que autant oui
c'est moi qui commande le vin
venir à Amsterdam pour une nuit de
débauche et une cuite c'est 140 euros
d'amende et un casier judiciaire
ça veut dire moins de perspectives
d'avenir
alors vous voulez vraiment venir
Amsterdam pour une nuit de débauche ne
venez pas buée de l'eau
s'il vous plaît 4 verres de vin 4 verres
d'eau par jour par jour
le matin
à midi dans l'après-midi et le soir au
dîner voilà allez commence
c'est pas terrible